[Music]
hi it's Michelle fool i bluffing beauty
science beauty nerd and sunscreen
connoisseur I recently went to Europe
specifically France and England and I
brought back a whole bunch of products
and a lot of you guys on Instagram asked
me to show you what I brought back and
so the fastest way I thought would be to
make this video I might sound a bit
weird because I actually managed to pop
my eardrum on the plane and I can't
really hear properly out of my right ear
I haven't tried out most of these
products yet so I'm just going to say
what stands out to me about them in
other words why they made it into my
suitcase I was about 7 kilos over the
weight limit but I managed to get
through without paying any extra baggage
fees so what I did was I had two kilos
over for my checked baggage and then I
had about 12 kilos in my backpack and I
put my backpack on and I tried to look
really casual walking through a backpack
I uses this which is the herschel pop
quiz it's amazing it just feels really
light and so I managed to get through
everything without getting caught
a popular products I also brought home a
whole bunch of nice clothes because
Australia is really bad for nice clothes
so things like Zara we just don't get
the same stock
I also brought back a whole bunch of
chocolate so I ended up being quite
selective I think about the products I
brought back but I did bring back a lot
so I'm gonna go through all of these
products and I'm going to try to keep it
to about 15 seconds per product which if
you've ever seen any of my other videos
you'll know that this is a massive
challenge so we'll see how this goes if
you like this sort of video give it a
thumbs up subscribe to my channel click
the notification button etc note that
some of the products I'm going to talk
about were PR samples I'll try to say
them when I come across them and also
nurture than the caption some of them
was a gifted by other people who I met
overseas who wanted me to review
particular products in particular Nadine
Baggett who I'm super grateful to I've
linked to our video channel below as
well her videos are really really great
alright here we go this is a tangle
teezer I've actually never tried them
before they are in Australia it's been
really really good at untangling my wet
hair this is from Nadine this is the
Kiehl's cannabis sativa seed or herbal
concentrate CBD and cannabis and all of
that is trending I don't think this is a
CBD oil I think it's
hempel but helpful is quite good for
oily skin because it has a lot of
linoleic triglycerides the inky list is
the brown which i've heard a lot about
it's not in Australia this is the
turmeric which is a moisturizer it is
supposedly good at fading pigmentation
this is another achelous product it's
poly glutamic acid I've heard it's
really good for moisturizing it's an
ingredient I've never tried before so
I'm quite curious this is the antigen
ultra nourishing anti irritation ciao
gel I've already tried it it's really
great this is a pyaar Sanibel it's got
tons of glycerin which I love and it's
really-really amoliant which is great
for dry skin in dry weather this is the
bio Gemma hydra bio SPF 30 spray it's
got PA plus plus plus
it's a moisturizing out to UV mist I've
been curious about mists sunscreens I
don't think it will provide a lot of
protection but I am curious to see how
it goes over the makeup this is the LA
roche-posay sick of last born b5 it's
really good for peeling skin I've used
it before in the past I also bought a
giant tube for my sister
it has centella this is the Bioderma
nerdy nerdy non detergent fluid shampoo
it's non detergent it does have
surfactants in it I think they're just
not anionic surfactants which is what
you usually find a shampoo I think quite
curious about it I've used it a little
bit already it's very liquidy it's been
really gentle on my scalp my scalp tends
to react quite a bit to SLS so yeah I've
got high hopes for this it's a bit
tricky to use I'm still trying to get
used to the liquid texture in France I
tend to have a lot of multi pack buys
for things like lip balm so I bought the
Atta germ ultra moisturizing lip balms
I've used one already it has a sort of
berry scent it's got this slanted top
which I'm not entirely convinced by so
far it's been really really moisturizing
it stays on all night it is very
nourishing
I've been obsessed with expanding dental
floss the one I've been using I can't
remember the name doctor tunnels doctor
tunnels but boots also has expanding
whitening floss which I'm quite excited
about I bought a whole bunch of these I
had a look at them though they don't
seem to expand as much as the doctor
tongue so I don't know will say this
I've been really curious about is the
color wild raincoat
I don't know how oh go on my wavy ish
hair it's quite interesting because
there's activated by dry heat so it's
not really your usual silicon or fatty
alcohol product it's got some sort of
polymer in it which I guess polymerizes
or forms a nice film when you heat it
but yes super interesting there are
certain ordinary products that you can't
get in Australia and this is one of them
this is the Alpha fusion I think
anything with alpha butan hasn't been
allowed in Australia so curious about
this one this is the dr. sounds flawless
cleanser I actually ordered this before
I went to the UK and received it where I
was staying
yes so it's not really foaming which is
a bit of a weird texture for me so far
it's been quite nice this is the sense
of buyer mild cleansing firming gel it
has been very mild it has been effective
at removing my makeup it was the pr
sample that i received on my pyoderma
trip this is the Marvis strong mint
mouthwash
i got this in my hotel actually as a
freebie unfortunately when i hid it in
my bag i did not get a refill pretty
upset about that i heard about Marvis on
this trip from other people on the trip
apparently it's really popular so i'm
excited to try this apparently just
tastes really nice because i heard so
much about mothers I also went off and
bought some of their toothpastes I
bought the Jasmine mint the ginger mint
and the classic strong mint I've tried
the Jasmine mint so far it tastes really
nice it tastes like jasmine tea I was
originally a bit concerned because it
didn't look like they have fluoride but
I believe they do it's just not written
on these little ones it's written on the
big one I will support a big one of the
Jasmine these are dry masks for a mister
Gasper I've been really interested about
these because they are dry but they're
like sheet masks and they're reusable so
I guess they'd like some sort of dry
moisturiser
they seem to have a lot of shea butter
in them I bought some of this Warren
homeo plasmon which is apparently a
homeopathic treatment don't really trust
homeopathy but I've heard that this is
really good for lips and for irritated
areas I've been using this on my
cuticles it's been working really well
it hasn't worked so well on my lips I
actually visited Jane Barber when I was
in London and we made a hair conditioner
together this is full of Mo dimethicone
I'm pretty excited to try it out I
haven't tried it out yet there will be a
video about how we made the conditional
this is a PR sample of estrogen ultra
soothing balm it's for a very dry
irritated atopic sensitive skin I was
using this on my hands on the plane on
the plane my cuticles just destroy
themselves and I always end up bleeding
but this worked really really well
highly recommended I also used it on my
face it was really really nice and
hydrating even though I have really dry
aircon hotel atmosphere I don't know why
but I decided to buy a whole bunch of
lip balms this is the seeker plus
barrier repairing balm from La Roche
Posay so far it's been working ok I
don't love the tube format I also bought
an LA roche-posay stick lip balm as well
I much prefer sticks I've tried it I
wasn't super impressed by it I actually
preferred the Bioderma one so far from
what I've tried I haven't tried them
very thoroughly though so that opinion
may change when I was in France I
managed to visit the biological Russia
I've visited their spa in Paris and I
bought some lotion p50 and lotion p50
pigment 400 these are cult products
especially the p50 which is the original
strong acid I've tried it it hasn't
really wowed me massively so far but I
haven't tried it long enough to really
see I also got a bunch of samples from
them unfortunately I've got a sample of
the p50 and the p50 pigment 400 which is
what I bought they also gave me a sample
of the bio magic mask the by magic mask
has clay and antioxidants they also gave
me the emulsion original regenerate
which is a moisturizer it's based on
Dyke a parallel carbonate which is one
of my favorite sunscreen ingredients or
sunscreen bases it's got squalane as
well and macadamia oil it looks like
will be a pretty nice moisturizer while
in London I also went with dr. Dennis
first event where I got some PR samples
of the alpha-beta peel I've used it so
far it's really really good I do really
like it it's got true parts it's got an
exfoliation treatment followed by an
anti-aging treatment so the exfoliation
treatment is aham DHA and the anti-aging
neutralizer is
more neutral you put it on two minutes
later it's called vitamin C so if I
worked really well I am a bit conflicted
about how it's meant to be single use
and it seems like a bit of a waste but I
have managed to get like four nights
worth out of it so like front back are
the front other back
so I guess partly this does solve my
conflicted feelings dr. Denis gross has
come out with the professional-grade
liquid peel the same sorts of step one
and step two alpha and beta hydroxy
acids followed by the anti-aging
neutralizer so the liquid peel has
lactic acid glycolic acid and bromelain
which is an enzyme exfoliant so I'm
pretty excited to try this the anti
aging neutralizer part has centella
which is really good for irritation
think it might be tea oil and colloidal
oatmeal which is again really really
good for irritation so I'm pretty
excited to try this especially since I
am using threatenin which means that
most of the time AJ and BHA products are
a little bit scary but this anti
irritation part is really promising for
that I also bought the outer dome SOS
spray based on an a recommendation on
Instagram it is supposedly meant to
soothe any itches within 60 seconds
which is pretty exciting one of my most
exciting purchases in Paris was this
Atelier cologne perfume which is the
orange sync wine it smells really good
it smells very citrusy they're famous
for their citrus scents it also came
with this personalized pouch it's gold I
stamped a gold M on it so at the same
hotel from Ken I also took some of the
bathroom amenities so this is the Diane
berry a shower gel smells really nice
pretty boring shower gel to be honest
it's got SLES
coke emitter purple B chain I also got
their body lotion again smells quite
nice pretty average said her alcohol
glycerine glycerine
so in the first leg of my trip I also
went to in cosmetics which is the
biggest conference for cosmetic
formulators and ingredients suppliers
yeah so one of the booths I visited was
the BASF booth and they have this new
ingredient which is actually I think
it's a range of three ingredients from
rambutan which is this like Eli
fruit they salsa from Vietnam it's
really interesting and they actually
formulated it into a few samples of
product which is apparently quite rare
for them so I have the Tron Tron shampoo
and conditioner these are anti pollution
they have rambutan actives in there
which is Ramba vital they also gave me a
gel cream which I've tried the texture
isn't great sorry guys it feels a little
bit like glue if you wanted a bit of
feedback on your formulation um it has
nefra net hydrate Neph hydrate and they
also gave me the night rejuvenating
booster which has nefaria so yeah those
are the three actives from the rambutan
i also have the event SPF 30 lip balm I
don't really use SPF lip balms but I
thought I'd try out one it probably
should use them and I also got two
little samples of Eucerin
so I got the Eucerin shower oil which
now that I'm into shower oils I'm pretty
excited about and also a little tube of
aqua fall I already use aqua 4 so it's
nice to get a little tube that I can
carry around
speaking of samples I got a whole bunch
of sample sachets from the French
pharmacy I went through user ins a
hydrator on filler CC cream which has
SPF 15 they gave me just a beige color I
also got a nukes oil sample which is a
floral version of their classic dry oil
I'm probably pronouncing all of these
freshening as well I'm sorry amber Elise
this is the concealer correcting care in
beige I also got a Vichy anti dandruff
shampoo and some will leader anti
cellulite oil
another thing that France does really
well is little travel packs so if you
buy a tiny sunscreen often you'll get it
in a handy travel bag with other
products so I got this with the Eucerin
SPF I also got some perfume samples from
Atelier cologne so they gave me Pamela
paradise Pacific lime and cedar ok so I
know you're probably wondering where's
all the sunscreen and that's because I
put the sunscreen in a separate bags
here it is okay so I got a sunscreen
from the ordinary we don't
get ordinary sunscreens in Australia
because Australia's got strict standards
about their sunscreen a lot of SPF
products can't be sold here this is the
mineral UV filters SPF 30 with
antioxidants I'm not really optimistic
about it because it is mineral filters
which tends to give me a white cast I
also got the Clarins dry touch Sun care
cream it's got SPF 30 I have the dr.
Dennis gross dark spot Sun defense Sun
screen broad-spectrum SPF 50 with
melissa complex this is the Eucerin sun
protection I got told that I needed to
get a user in sunscreen so here it is
it's SPF 50 plus I'm really excited
about this this is the bio Gemma photo
germ SPF 50 plus I bought it because
it's a mousse I really like mousse
textures for fake tans so I'm excited to
try out this mousse texture for a
sunscreen which I've never tried before
this is the photo germ new touch SPF 50
plus it's basically like a light
foundation apparently it dries down to a
really nice matte powder finish which
I'm excited about it doesn't feel like a
powder finish coming out it feels much
more oily this was a PR sample that I
got from the Bioderma trip this is the
bio dome a photo dome mattes
SPF 50 plus this one I got because it's
got really high UVA protection this is
the milk the milk texture is apparently
one of their most popular when you go
into a pharmacy in France you will
discover that there are millions of
versions of everything so I think of the
photo dome max there were like 4
different versions so I picked one at
random the milk apparently it's for
normal skin so hopefully pretty excited
about this this is the Kiehl's ultra
light daily UV defense it's SPF 50 PA
with full plusses it's an anti-pollution
sunscreen I also got a lot of requests
for me to try that la roche-posay and
Helios 50 plus shakka fluid so this is a
shaking one I haven't had much luck with
fluid textures in the past I know
they're meant to be for oily skin but my
oily skin doesn't like them it just
makes my skin oily err so I'll be
interesting to see how this goes I had a
lot of requests to try Beauty PI but I
think it's like some membership system
and it's like a postage thing so I did
wasn't really organized
to title but I did get this from Nadine
this is the beauty pie ultralight UVA
UVB SPF 25 25 is a bit lower for me as
an Australian but we'll see how it goes
this is the Helio Kerr 360 fluid cream
it is from the company that makes foam
block which is like a fern extract which
you take orally and it's meant to be a
supplement that gives you internal SPF
protection
apparently it's only like SPF 3 or
something but it is a supplement that
you take so you don't have to worry
about it wearing off I am curious about
their sunscreen products so it still has
firm Block in it so I guess it's some
sort of antioxidant yes as SPF 50 plus
it does also supposedly have protection
against high-energy visible light and
infrared light as well and that is it so
I hope you like this video I know it's a
little bit different from what I usually
do but I hope you found it interesting
if you like to give it a thumbs up
subscribe to my channel also let me know
which products you want me to actually
try out properly on my skin you can also
follow me on instagram at lab muffin
beauty signs and you can check out my
blog for more beauty signs info as well
see you next time